hello everyone and welcome to a very
enjoyable game between Garry Kasparov
and the one and only Woody Harrelson and
now I don't know how many of you enjoy
Woody Harrelson if I see any movie is
with Woody Harrelson I will watch the
movie even if the movie sucks his acting
will we'll make it you know bearable so
that being said how did the two of them
meet and how did this match even happen
well it was in 1999 Garry Kasparov was
organizing a chess match between Alexey
sure of and you did polgár and it was
played in Prague and won one of the
people in the audience was actually
Woody Harrelson and he decided to he
decided to steal the show and show cause
part of that he is a natural-born killer
in chess as well and they play the game
we even have a photo of this event it's
it's not the greatest quality photo but
there's Kasparov on the left and Woody
Harrelson on the right Harrelson with
the white pieces and you okay it's it's
a bit blurry but I'm sure you can see
that Harrelson has a Queen Anne on h4 on
the board which which is very
interesting how the Queen is already on
h4 straight from the opening now there
is a twist to this game but I will save
that for the end of the video so let's
see the game Woody Harrelson has the
white pieces and Kasparov is black we
have E 4 E 5 and already unturned - and
move - we have Queen to h5 so Woody
Harrelson it is either attempting the
fools mate against Kasparov or he has
some ideas about going Queen h5 and he's
not I mean he's not a stranger to chest
as he did stop by to check out the match
hero versus polgár while returning from
his movie festival in Carlsbad as part
of defends the pawn on e5 Knight to c6
and here we have Bishop to c4 so already
Harrelson is threatening Queen captures
on f7 checkmate and there are there are
various ways you can prevent this you
can go g6 you can kick away the Queen
you can go Queen to e7 you can go Queen
to f6 a lot of ideas here and this is
one of the problems
as soon as you see someone play Eve or
queen h5 Bishop to c4 you know he's a
noob and you're gonna win this game is
black but there is a problem you never
actually gave yourself any any time to
analyze this at home because you know
that no one will play this if you play
in a strong tournament or something so
you never really saw g6 Queen to d1 as a
viable option and then would where to go
from here with black you just know that
okay if someone plays this with white
I'll just kick the Queen away and then
you know continue my game with black
hand all the books say that this is bad
for white so I must be winning here but
after Bishop to c4 Kasparov went Queen
to e7 which is also which is also an
excellent option this stops stops
checkmate and white white simply has a
poorly placed Queen on h5 or does he we
have Knight to f3 developing the knight
and the knight to f6 attacking the Queen
and now Queen to h4 from HP from h4 the
queen is also guarding the pawn on e4
and now d6 we have b3 h6 and h3 so all
standard moves Bishop to e6 offering a
trade bishops and knife to c3 by
Harrison so going for that development
but rook captures on c4 d captures on c4
he doesn't mind doubling up his C points
because he now has a firm grip on the d5
square Knight to d4 by Kasparov Knight
captures pawn captures and now what do
you do with the night Iori for pawn is
attacked twice do go Knight b5 do go
Knight e - or do you go Knight to d5
tell the truth how many of you would
play Knight to d5 of course if you do
this you immediately lose the game due
to Knight captures here now your queen
is attacked and you just lost the piece
so if you capture the knight you lose
the Queen and if you capture the Queen
then Knight capture screen and you're
down a piece but you know this happens
to everyone at least once so no shame so
after it captures on d4 Knight to e2 now
d4 pawn is under attack but also
Harrelson is attacking the d4 pawn so
before capturing he
first as part of defense the phone with
c5 we have f3 now defending d4 pawn and
d5 a nice little tactic that gets rid of
the double D pawn kasparov has so C
captures and now Knight captures Knight
characters here and here we have Queen
captures on e7 of course you can't
capture the night because you lose the
Queen on h4 so Queen captures and Knight
captures the Queen back and now Bishop -
D - we have castles by Kasparov castles
by Harrelson and g6 Kasparov is ready to
develop his dark square Bishop on g7
Knight to f4 and Bishop to g7 so if you
look at the position to position is
pretty equal the material is completely
equal and of course it's it doesn't mean
that it's a drawn game of one player is
power of the other is who Woody
Harrelson
I'm sure if if they really had this
position in a serious tournament over
the board Casper would of course would
of course win this game but as it was an
exhibition game I don't think that too
much thought was given to this game C
for gaining an even firmer grip on the
d5 square preparing Knight to d5
we have D captors on c3 on Poisson a
Bishop captures Bishop captures and pawn
captures so removing even more material
from the board b6
we have c4 now Knight comes to c6
preparing Knight to d4 so now Harrison
does have a firm grip on the d5 square
but he also weakened did the d4 square
so Kasparov takes advantage of this we
have King 2b to rook to e8 now rook
captures rook captures exchanging a pair
of rooks
and now Knight finally does come to d5 h
v by Kasparov we have a for King to d7
and King to c3 King te vi as part of
activates his King we have F for not
allowing the King to come anywhere near
the position Knights to d4 and rook to
d1 so if you look at this position now
again the material is completely equal
as part of does have somewhat better
pawn structure he has to pawn islands
Harrison has 3 points but it's
it's not not at all simple - to do
anything about this so in the game
Knight to e2 was played King to c2 and
now Knight back to d4 King to C 3 and
after Caspar repeated Knight to e2 the
players agreed to a draw as a woody
harrelson had to leave I believe he had
a plane to catch
but even if you even if you don't force
a draw here for example even if you
continue with black something like h4
then then white can attempt to force the
draw with 97 check King g7 and then
let's say Knight back to d5 check and if
the King goes here or here Knight to c7
will be repeated your rook will come
under attack from the rook on d1 and if
you don't do this if you decide to go
something like King to d6 then you allow
me five White will slowly improve his
position and most likely it will still
end up in a draw so yeah after this
Knight to e2 check as the players agree
to a draw and you know this is quite
quite an accomplishment such an
accomplished actor Woody Harrelson and
he can boast that in 1999 he drew a
world champion Garry Kasparov but now
comes the twist
Woody Harrelson did not play this game
alone it is known that he was aided by
two grandmasters from the audience who
were spectating this game one of them
was grandmaster yasser sarah 1 so it's
not familiar to what extent was were
they aiding him or was this after a 45
Queen to h5 was this move also suggested
by yasser or the other grandmaster i I
don't think so I think the first couple
of moves were actually Woody Harrelson's
moves but it's not it's not known to
what extent they were they were aiding
Woody Harrelson and the Dutch Grand
Master Hans ray also said about this
game that it doesn't matter that Woody
Harrelson was aided by the two
grandmasters it also shows that queen h5
might not be such a bad idea for white I
mean you know feel free feel free to
play this you know if a grandmasters
plays Queen to h5 against you you're not
really gonna refute this and crushing
with black you know as you've seen seen
in this game if if white played it you
know just one
bad move of course could borrow would
crush him but he didn't and so you know
even though he had he had a plane to
catch
they did draw this game and no sides
made any mistakes so I guess a draw a
draw is pretty fair so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it this isn't
this isn't the only game because part of
played against a celebrity there are
some other games and I will also include
this probably in my next couple of
videos but until then there is a link in
the description below where you can vote
on my next series so what will we do
will be something like kappa blanka yeah
him maybe something more modern by bobby
fischer or even a ladder so there will
be a link in the description be sure to
check it out and give your vote and yeah
40 and we can we can check out this
photo
one more time it's not the greatest
quality but it's the only one we have so
yeah I would like to thank Tony more
what guitar matias we need ski and
Kelsie Roberts for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you